Live Wire so so incredibly great oh
thank you I felt like I was just sitting
with you and honey you were well you
would get it because you're a working
woman I'm A working woman and I've
chatted with you but I also watch the
show and I'm sure so many people as they
come up to you and clearly tell you they
know you because they watch you on
television yeah I mean it's a real it's
a privilege I mean like not to be one of
these people that go as I said in the
book right but I talk about how much the
audience and I have been there for each
other it's a privilege of doing this job
where you get to be in the homes of
people every day and it's a constant and
and so it's it's a constant even though
our show is very irreverent there's a
certain reverence in knowing that people
are still all of these years later I've
been doing it for 23 years
um still inviting me in
um with my kid brother the Boy Wonder
trying
now here are Kelly Ripa and Ryan
Seacrest
you are very open about your auditions
negotiations for live in this book you
say that seniority was used a lot and as
it turns out seniority is a masculine
word so here are
Regis Philbin
this many years into the game here at
live has that game changed have you seen
that Trend change I don't
I don't necessarily know if I've seen it
change
um I think it definitely is more
Amplified because I Amplified a lot and
we work in a in a in a household of a
lot of women and the more women that
come in the more equalizing it can be
um but I I do think that seniority is
something that is typically only uh
thought of uh as masculine but we as
women need to get behind each other and
um and by and by that I mean it starts
with getting behind yourself
you can't get behind your sisters if you
can't get behind yourself
and that is something that I
seek to do because it really is like a
love letter to women it's a love letter
to people in the workplace who may have
felt um marginalized in some way viewers
have assumed and wondered behind the
scenes what your relationship was like
with Regis you held my hand and you said
look sweetheart all these people are
here to see you and that was like so
nice to put me at ease that he told me
they were here to see me how would you
describe how your relationship was like
with Regis I had and still have enormous
respect admiration and reverence for
Regis
I like most of the viewing public
felt like I knew him
but to expect two people from such
different generations to have some sort
of weird forced friendship when they
never knew each other is a very strange
thing to put on one person and it was
only put on one person and that is how I
describe it it's we had a very
professional working relationship that
used to be a celebrated thing but in
this weird Gonzo tabloidy let's pit the
man against the woman world that we live
in somehow that was straight it was
strange and I was vilified and so that's
why I address it in the book it it was
we had a professional working
relationship and that's what we had and
that's okay because we are from
different Generations we have different
friend groups and we had different
professional backgrounds you know it
took me five years to learn to look into
the camera because I was trained to
never break the fight you were coming
from I'm coming from the acting world
and so there is no class for this they
didn't teach me how to do this you learn
on the job right we all learned on the
job everybody here that works in this
building can tell you you learn on the
Fly absolutely and to also learn in the
book that you had social anxiety yeah
fear of public speaking I'm like what I
don't get it it's all about knowing who
you are and what your weak points are
you know but every day I'm I'm positive
I'll turn that I'll turn my fear of
public speaking around Kelly you're an
open book on the show but this goes even
a step further it's not like you're just
documenting in your own personal Journal
this is a published Memoir a book of
essays so why do of essays by now well
you know I thought like a like a fool
and an imbecile and I keep saying this
that uh if the gyms were open during the
pandemic this book would not exist so
don't blame me blame the gyms
but I started recounting moments of my
life that were meant to be funny and
humorous and all of that and 99 of the
book is some of it is gritty and and
um you know more on the serious side but
um I think that I thought a book of
essays would be easier and it turns out
I was I was wrong I was incorrect it
would have been easier to write a memoir
but I don't feel that I met the Memoir
phase of my life I feel like I have
other things I want to do there are
other things I want to achieve this
seemed like just funny stories that
people could digest easily individually
and there's a little something for
everyone without a doubt speaking of
funny how about the very intimate story
you tell of passing out during having
sex with Mark well it's more of a story
about how
hard
um intimacy can be for women
particularly after they've had a baby
exactly and and I am no different that
was hard for me it was very very
difficult and really what it portrays is
and rightly so that my husband in that
in that time and he was keeping in mind
he was 27 years old he's a 27 year old
kid that knew exactly almost what to do
and gave me the support I needed before
there was language that there was no
language about
supporting uh postnatal women and what
they
what their bodies may be going through
and what they things they may not have
even thought of right and it really is
more I mean I think of like most of this
book as a love letter to Mark and that's
why I dedicated the book to him because
he really has walked through
you know most of my adult life with me
we feel like you're getting emotional no
I mean you're not he's he is such a good
he's a great husband he's a great father
he's a great guy but he's a great friend
that's the greatest thing he is a friend
and if you have him as a friend you've
hit the jackpot yeah do you feel like
that's been the key to your relationship
the friendship between the two because
you've been saying here that couples
like you and Mark usually do not work
out they don't make it no I mean I
didn't I don't think either one of us
thought we would make it yeah because we
went off to Vegas we were 25 years old
we eloped we have a 25 year old if he
ran off to Vegas and elope we would
punish him we would block him into Vegas
and you would find him we would find him
and lock him in his old room oh my God
but you know
um
it's one of those things that I on paper
should not have worked out we should not
have worked out but something about the
two of us and I think that it's our
mutual respect we have mutual admiration
and we don't
compete with each other we don't have
egos where the other person is concerned
we are like we have each other's backs
and that's a unique thing I think in
this industry and you know in a business
of what we do we just like really are
always there for each other absolutely
and especially when you both are
juggling so much and you take readers
there and fool me once for me twice you
talk about juggling all my children and
your live auditions and you're also
pregnant I mean and you're newly married
I mean there are just so many layers to
this yeah I think that people get
confused and I've been asked this a
thousand times
why don't you act anymore why don't you
do this anymore why aren't you doing
that you need to leave that place you
need to go off and do this and I always
say I've made a choice because
everything exists because of this job
now I'm not saying I exist because of
this job because I had a job you know I
was an actor I made a choice in my life
to to experience the exhilarating fun
crackly effervescent
but
not easy sometimes when things look easy
they're actually quite difficult and
staying Nimble and staying engaged for
decades is no easy feat and it's
something that women in particular don't
get credit for ever and so that's why I
wrote that chapter and that's why I talk
about it
you are a completely open book when it
comes to cosmetic surgery and tabloids
you talk about Botox you talk about
plastic surgery procedures and the
tabloids just really having their fun
with you whenever you were first coming
onto the scene here at live I was 30
years old and they were talking about
why I looked youthful and I was like
piano just me because I'm 30 years old I
am young and so when I started reading
about all of these cosmetic procedures
that I was allegedly having done I was
kind of insulted and mad and then you
get riveted yeah yeah you know
um particularly the boob jobs like that
was a headline what went wrong I was
like did I miss my appointment for them
is that what went wrong but it was like
endless endless endless exhausting yeah
kind of boring then it became dumb and
then it stopped and then then I was like
I need BOTOX for reals because as long
as they were writing about it I had to
look pretty good right I I guess that
was my mentality my mentality was like I
must not need it if they think I'm
getting it I must not need anything but
even the fact that you have to think
about these things are being written
about you they're clearly not true what
has given you this tough thick skin Oh I
don't have a thick skin and I'm not
tough no I've never I've just like put
it where it belongs like in the bottom
of the bird feeder cage you know what I
mean it's like that's where it belongs
that's not
smart journalism it's not interesting
it's not it's not creative it's not
original
um and so that's why I write about it in
the detail with which I write about it I
also drag the the viewer the reader back
in time because there was no social
media there were no ways to address
these things on your own right
you had to either bring it up and
elevate it or swallow it and I always
chose to swallow it because otherwise
you make it even longer otherwise you
make it larger you help them sell their
Rags for them and I was like more of
like don't give a fire oxygen
um but you know it I just like to
reference points in time throughout the
years and how things like sometimes when
left unchecked can become facts works of
facts instead of works of fiction you
were open about the neck surgery was
there any aspect of you that was
hesitant about touching upon that
procedure no none because I want to hear
it because I think that again I'm gonna
I'll do the double standard again men
get praised for talking about this stuff
yeah and women get mercifully torn apart
for it and so they don't talk about it
and so therefore all women think they're
the only woman I did that I was the only
woman aging I thought I was the only
woman in the history of Show Business to
age and it's funny once you start
talking about it openly then everybody
around you starts talking about it
openly and you realize that you're late
to the game at least I realized I was
late to the game and I did not know that
you know I just thought I was the only
one Kelly you are pure perfection and so
is this but I can't wait for number two
no no yeah as I wrote no if I try to do
this again somebody has to suffocate me
with a pillow
foreign